in a musical it's very important that
songs start naturally
and we we planted some wind chimes
in the tree there and if you pay
attention you can hear
the beginning notes of rocket to the
moon but
they're just from the wind making these
chimes
and hit those beautiful little notes and
and wind to me is always
a symbol of a spiritual presence
a gentle breeze that starts music
in the wind and the animation you use
all of it together
to create a spell for the audience the
heavens
and i can see your face your
gentle eyes in moonlight i feel your
warm embrace
audrey uh wrote this script
as a love letter to her daughter um
because she knew at the time she was
writing it that
um she probably would not live to see
this film
completed early on as we were figuring
out
our casting for faith um we
brought kathy yang and just to do some
scratch um
and some demo records of the songs um
and
there's a quality about kathy that just
brings out this
um this innocence but also this
determination
and the character and i think she
emulated all the things we wanted to
highlight in in this
in this character can you see
why
the truly unique thing about that take
um was not just that it was the first
time she sang it ever
but also that usually in a film you
might take
different parts from different takes
and piece them together and you always
kind of do that to try and find the best
version of the song as a whole
but her take is a complete
take just one take she did it all
in one go and that truly is the version
that's in the film
in my rocket two
[Music]
it was second week march we all the
whole world got the call
you know everybody go home we were five
to six weeks away from finishing
just animation we still had to go
through lighting and comp and post and
you know record the score and all of
those things that you
typically would do in person and all of
us were kind of in this
place of the unknown we we didn't know
was it going to be two weeks
four weeks and here we are a year later
and
just amazing how dedicated everybody was
[Music]
so here we find feife at the end of the
movie
she's gone to the moon and back and
gone through an incredible healing
learning to love somebody new
and they have this wonderful bond
together
but this scene is really about
a time for the audience to reflect
i feel like this scene is really the
moment
um where we see fife connect
with her mother in the form of this
beautiful white bird and
that they are able to have this moment
of peace together
where the mother knows that fife is
healed
and that she can move on as well and
it's
so beautiful the acting feels so natural
it was just the way that
faith phase kneels down on
to that stone kids are so flexible she
can have both of her
knees kind of stretched out flat jenny
reminded me
of your son that he would come to
work and you'd see him just fold up like
that and
it was like so i storyboarded this
thinking of him and the way he
kneeled knelt down and
it's really just a testament to
the animation team that put that kind of
truth in this and that scarf represents
her mom
too it's a drawing actually i did of
chong
that we placed on that scarf
and in the beginning you watch
those um that silk design
turn into hand-drawn animation it was
very important for me that
changa be represented
in the most referential way because we
were going to be
borrowing changa from the chinese
culture and we were basically going to
turn her
upside down on her head and we had to
bring her back to that place of dignity
and when i look at
this moment here where fei-fei looks at
changha
on that scarf i'm so happy that
what we present is a change that
has healed is deeper
is warmer is it it's all in that
expression there's a dignity and there's
a grace
to her and that's what right after it
feife
holds that scarf and treasures the
memory that she's had
of changa and her mom it's everything
comes together in this moment of
valuing the journey that she's been on
and this is something she treasures in
that pose
and the surprise visit of
this white bird there's something about
it it was very important this bird be
very real and
face squints like do i know you and
birds can be kind of scary
when they're looking at you and we
worked really hard to give
just this tiniest little corner of a
smile
as the birth looks and even softening
partly an eyebrow but i mean so much
that you would never
see it but just makes it a little bit
warmer
and connects with fei-fei another thing
i love about
this moment is it actually is a moment
that is about
dad having healed as well
and the journey that he's gone through
um in this film because
this moment this conversation he has
with faye is the first time
he's acknowledged mom in this whole
movie
i also particularly love the interaction
that they have because i
felt like also it was so
culturally authentic to the chinese
culture the way
that he expresses himself and the words
he says
you know he cares about her more than
anything in the world you know that they
love each
other um and i think that's another
layer to this scene that i think is
so special we remote end uh at like
we'd start at 2am and um all of us
would be on these room calls listening
to this beautiful beautiful score
i mean it was such a wonderful thing to
experience
um and you know we would be sending
notes via
text messages and then we you know it
was just like this really
amazing way of communicating um when we
could have all just been there but
we figured it out and it was really
because everybody just leaned in and was
like you know let's
let's make it work and again those
musicians
um our composer stephen price um
everybody at the synchron stage like
they just went above and beyond to
make sure everybody was safe but also to
deliver what was
an exceptional score and jenny what
you're you're talking about with
steven's score
i can never watch this scene here
without choking up uh
but it's the emotion of that score as
the white bird flies over fifa's head
and
then this this beautiful melody
[Music]
and steven recorded that i think was on
christmas night
he said by himself he just played the
guitar
and he had a glass of wine and he
whistled and that
simple little melody here is just
growing swelling swelling and
it's oh yeah it was at three o'clock in
the morning i remember them recording
this and
imagining this day i mean even just
talking about it now
it really really is special i think the
fact that the entire crew was
living through this global pandemic of
uncertainty
we woke in mourning certain that we were
gonna
lean into making this film i think each
one of us
knew that this film was so special and
that
you know it wasn't just about getting
across the finish line it was about
let's let's honor this film and and make
it the best that we can